Ah les cabinets de curiosités...
Petits papillons sous cloche, minéraux précieux ornés d’or, ils sont de véritables écrins
hyper chics de collections d’objets chelous.
L’art, la nature et la science s'y acoquinent depuis la Renaissance et encore aujourd’hui ils sont de vrais phénomènes de mode.
En 1492, Christophe Colomb découvre l’Amérique.
Et c’est précisément dans ce contexte d’explorations géographiques et de découvertes de nouvelles terres
que les premiers cabinets de curiosités naissent à la fin du XVème siècle en Europe,
et plus précisément en Italie du Nord sous le nom de studioli.
Ce sont des lieux privés réservés à l’étude et au savoir, qui sont réservés à créer une ambiance favorisant ce qu’on appelle la libido sciendi, ou le désir d'apprendre,
d’embrasser la connaissance.
Le tout dans un esprit d’émerveillement, d’étonnement et de contemplation.
A l’époque, la vision du monde change dans les esprits, s'élargit, et ouvre des portes sur de nouvelles sciences.
Tout ça va alors titiller la curiosité de princes, de savants ou encore de riches amateurs de cette époque.
Ils se mettent alors à convoiter et collectionner des objets curieux, dans une optique de condenser et matérialiser une certaine vision du monde
qui est résumée à ces objets.
Les collectionneurs vont donc convoiter autant d’objets naturels venant des 4 coins du monde
comme des coquillages ou des végétaux séchés, que des objets artificiels comme des instruments scientifiques,
des livres ou des œuvres d’art par exemple, mais aussi des bizarreries en tous genres.
Et ils vont ensuite les réunir dans des lieux dédiés.
Le concept arrivera ensuite à Munich, sous le nom de kunstkammer
qui deviendra lui-même le modèle de ce qu’on appelle les wunderkammer
qui signifient littéralement “chambre des merveilles”
On les appelle les collectionneurs, ou les “curieux”.
Étymologiquement parlant, Curiosité vient de cura, qui veut dire la cure, comme dans cure ou curatif.
Donc littéralement, le curieux devient celui, ou celle, qui prend soin.
Savants ou collectionneurs princiers rassemblent et possèdent une collection incroyable d’objets rares et mystérieux.
Et plus une collection était grande et comportait des pièces rares, plus cela ajoutait évidemment au prestige social de son propriétaire.
C’est une vraie démonstration de faste et de richesse.
Bon, parce que, pour être collectionneur, il fallait avoir un peu de thunes.
Du coup, le besoin de trouver un lieu dédié pour entasser toutes ces petites merveilles et babioles a vite pointé le bout de son nez.
Et quand on a de la thune, et bah on voit les choses en GRAND.
A la Renaissance, en Italie, on amasse des objets dans des pièces de riches demeures.
Et le moins qu’on puisse dire c’est que l’accumulation y est alors le mot d’ordre.
Les collectionneurs  accumulent toutes les merveilles possibles de l’Univers dans les limites d’une pièce étroite,
dans une volonté de reconstituer un monde en miniature
et d’en offrir une image intelligible.
Ces lieux sont souvent étroits, privés, secrets, personnels mais aussi spectaculaires.
L’ambiance y est bien particulière, et laisse entrevoir une organisation spatiale imaginée par son collectionneur.
Ils peuvent aussi prendre la forme de meubles construits sur mesure pour mettre en boîte le monde.
Et c’était pas genre votre étagère Billy de chez Ikea non, mais plutôt des meubles ultra sophistiqués et très stylés.
Souvent en ébène, en noyer ou en sapin, c’est un meuble incrusté de petites pierres ou d’écailles.
Il est conçu pour accumuler et dispose d’une multitude de tiroirs débordant d’objets entassés.
Ces meubles sont placés dans des salles reculées, ou des chambres un peu intimes, pour favoriser l’isolement et la contemplation,
pour donner envie de connaître le monde.
Bon, le moins qu’on puisse dire, c’est que les traces qu’on a des premiers cabinets de curiosités font penser à des bon gros bordel.
Parce que c’est bien d’accumuler, mais comment ils faisaient pour un peu ranger toutes ces pièces en mode random ?
Du coup, que contenaient ces cabinets de curiosités, et comment s’organisent-ils ?
Si des représentations gravées et des catalogues publiés nous soufflent leurs contenus de l’époque,
il semblerait qu’à chaque curieux son propre cabinet et sa propre organisation.
Ils contiennent tous des mélanges hétéroclites d’objets comme des animaux en bocaux, des herbiers,
des pierres précieuses, des instruments scientifiques, des peintures, des taxidermies, des antiquités, mais aussi des morceaux d’animaux légendaires…
Voici une estampe datant de 1655 présentée sur une double page en frontispice d’un ouvrage du XVIIe siècle.
Intitulée Museum Wormianum Historia.
C’est l’une des premières représentations d’un cabinet de curiosités et c’est celui d’Olaus Worm, un professeur de médecine d’origine danoise
considéré comme le fondateur de l’archéologie nordique.
Et cette gravure nous souffle comment ces lieux tentaient de s’organiser.
On y voit l’intérieur d’une pièce dans laquelle sont accumulés un tas d’objets du sol au plafond et sur les étagères
comme des carapaces de tortues, des armes, des coquillages, des crânes, des peaux, des statuettes, des objets insolites dans des boîtes,
mais aussi des coraux, des cailloux, des végétaux...
On y perçoit, au milieu du désordre ambiant, des inscriptions en latins sur les boîtes et les étagères,
indiquant finalement une certaine volonté de classer ce gros bordel…
Si chaque curieux expérimente des solutions personnelles pour tenter d’ordonner ses collections, elles s’organisent généralement en quatre catégorie distinctes :
- Les naturalia pour tout ce qui concerne le minéral, l’animal et le végétal,
- les artificialia pour les objets façonnés par l’humain comme les antiquités et les oeuvres art,
- les exotica pour les plantes et animaux exotiques et les objets provenant de pays lointains,
- les scientifica pour les objets scientifiques comme des instruments par exemple,
ou encore les mirabilia pour les objets bizarres suscitant l’émerveillement.
Ces derniers recelaient des collections d’objets étranges et inusuels réunis dans des maisons particulières,
destinés à être consultés par des esprits éduqués et raffinés (c’est-à-dire les classes fortunées).
Selon l’anthropologue Gilles Boëtsch, « parallèlement à la “zoologie classique”, les cabinets de curiosités cherchaient aussi à réunir des fragments
de créatures du monde de légendes sans oublier les maints corps imaginaires censés avoir appartenu à tel ou tel monstre célébré dans la littérature ou les contes populaires ».
Au travers de ces catégories, un soin tout particulier est apporté à la présentation des objets.
Ils sont ornés, suspendus au plafond, mis en cloches, dressés sur des promontoires précieux fabriqués par des artisans
ou encore accrochés aux murs comme des peintures de maîtres, pour souligner la préciosité et le côté unique de ces pièces.
Ici, le banal n’a pas sa place,
les objets doivent être rares, remarquables, et susciter l’émerveillement.
Pour mettre en valeur ces pièces, les curieux font appel à des artisans pour les restaurer, les lisser,
les polir, mais altérant parfois la pièce originale à l’extrême.
Dans un article sur les coquillages, Jean Baptiste Lamarck ou “Jean-Baptiste Pierre Antoine de Monet, chevalier de La Marck”.
Rien que ça. Ou JB pour les intimes si vous préférez,
grand naturaliste et père du transformisme en France, note que les coquilles étaient souvent dénaturées et « mutilées par l'art ».
Les coquilles sont limées, usées, polies pour faire ressortir la nacre, ce qui fait disparaître les écailles et tubercules caractéristiques de celles-ci,
empêchant de les identifier correctement.
Un contraste s’installe donc petit à petit entre ce désir des curieux de provoquer l’émerveillement au maximum,
et celui des savants de vouloir identifier ou caractériser ces pièces rares pour poser petit à petit les fondements de l’Histoire naturelle.
Et cette volonté de sublimer les curiosités va parfois si loin que les curieux n’hésitent pas par exemple à monter des coquillages rares sur du bronze doré
et pour les transformer en récipients comme des aiguières, des genres de carafes d’eau.
Des œufs d’autruche ou des noix de coco deviennent quant à eux de jolies coupes, dans une volonté d’entrecroiser le naturel et l’artificiel,
pour compléter la création divine naturelle et la création artificielle de la main de l’humain.
Mais si les cabinets de curiosités offrent des objets précieux et clinquants, ils deviennent aussi les vitrines d’une nature imparfaite et étrange.
L’attirance vers le bizarre et les anomalies de la nature se manifestent
également dans des curiosités témoignant de sa nature accidentelle, voire monstrueuse.
La tératologie,est l’étude scientifique des anomalies anatomiques, héréditaires ou congénitales.
Cette discipline s’est développée à partir du XVIIIe siècle,
mais les monstres suscitent intérêt et fascination depuis la plus lointaine antiquité.
Dans certaines cultures, on leur attribuait même des vertus prophétiques.
Ainsi, 700 ans avant JC, les chaldéens gravaient sur des tablettes d’argiles les prédictions liées à certaines malformations.
Par exemple, si un enfant naissait sans main droite, le pays subirait un tremblement de terre.
Et si la Reine accouchait d’un enfant à six orteils,
le roi gouvernerait un territoire ennemi.
On pense aussi que la représentation de certains dieux a pu être influencée par des anomalies physiques.
C’est par exemple le cas du dieu grec Janus,
dont les deux visages rappellent ceux des janiceps,
des jumeaux à deux faces dont le nom fait référence à la divinité.
On peut aussi citer les dieux hindous à plusieurs membres, qui auraient pu être inspirés par l’observation de jumeaux conjoints
ou encore tout le bestiaire mythologique avec les sirènes ou les cyclopes.
Avec le temps et les avancées scientifiques,
les superstitions liées aux monstres vont laisser place à l’analyse.
On comprend que les malformations sont le fruit d’incidents biologiques,
et qu'elles ne sont pas dues à des amours démoniaques par exemple, comme on pouvait le croire au Moyen-Age.
C’est avec le naturaliste Étienne Geoffroy Saint-Hilaire, au début du XIXe siècle, que la tératologie va vraiment devenir une science.
Celui-ci comprend que ces anomalies anatomiques sont liées à un mauvais développement de l’embryon.
A partir de cette époque, on assiste à un nouvel engouement pour les monstres,
non plus comme créatures surnaturelles, mais comme objets d’études.
Les médecins et les chirurgiens vont chercher à obtenir les spécimens les plus étranges
pour les placer dans leurs cabinets de curiosités, et certains ont moins de scrupules que d’autres.
C’est notamment le cas de Robert Liston.
Dans les années 1830, ce chirurgien écossais voulait à tout prix étudier un enfant hydrocéphale vivant dans la campagne londonienne,
une pathologie entraînant une excroissance crânienne impressionnante.
L’enfant était si convoité par les savants qu'à sa mort, en 1838, ses parents firent garder sa tombe pour la protéger des profanateurs.
Un mois plus tard, cependant, la dépouille avait disparu.
Liston nia toute implication dans cette histoire, mais en 1840,
il publia dans son livre “Element of surgery” un dessin de squelette d’enfant hydrocéphale qui rappelait étrangement celui du jeune garçon.
Au début du XIXe siècle, le zoologiste Isidore Geoffroy Saint-Hilaire poursuit l'œuvre de son père
et publie un traité qui fera date dans l’histoire de la tératologie :
Histoire générale et particulière des anomalies de l’organisation chez l’Homme et les animaux.
Dans cet ouvrage, qui sera notamment cité par Darwin,
Saint Hilaire propose une classification anatomique des monstres en 4 niveaux,
allant d’anomalies simples tels que les cyclocéphaliens doté d’un seul œil,
a des anomalies très complexes et graves, comme des monstres composés, qui sont principalement formés par la fusion de deux corps.
Mais malgré ces avancées scientifiques, pour le grand public,
le statut des monstres ne change pas vraiment : ils restent ceux que l’on montre, et c’est d’ailleurs l'étymologie du terme.
Comme en témoigne le succès des freakshows de l’époque, les gens restent fascinés par l'étrange et le bizarre.
Et ce goût pour l’étrange et le bizarre va aussi se retrouver dans des pièces qu’on appelle alors les mirabilia.
Des objets à la limite de la magie, au pouvoir occulte et talismanique,
comme du sang de dragon séché ou des squelettes d’animaux légendaires, qui vont ouvertement flirter avec la fausse science.
Une des curiosités qu’on s’arrache à l’époque est le rémora,
un poisson ventouse à tête plate.
Ouais ok, comme ça c’est pas très sexy, mais il est à l’époque dans TOUS les cabinets de curiosités.
Pourtant assez classique d'apparence et très répandu,
il déchaîne les passions.
Il est en fait convoité car très présent dans une vaste littérature lui étant consacrée, et ça depuis l’Antiquité.
La légende raconte qu’il a des pouvoirs surnaturels, et qu’il est même capable d’arrêter un navire dans sa course en se collant à lui.
Cette légende fut lancée par Ovide, puis développée par Pline l’ancien, qui parle d’une galère qui fut arrêtée par un rémora,
empêchant le massacre des jeunes garçons de l'île de Cnide.
Le cabinet de curiosités devient donc le théâtre du fantastique.
Les sciences et les croyances populaires flirtent et s’entremêlent.
Les pierres d'origine animale font aussi fureur, comme les fossiles mais aussi des concrétions pour le moins insolites.
Par exemple, les bézoards qui sont des pierres que l'on trouve dans le corps de certains quadrupèdes.
C’est une concrétion légèrement souple, formée de couches concentriques autour d’un corps étanger dans l'appareil digestif de certains ruminants
comme les chèvres.
Il est à l’époque considéré comme un antipoison extrêmement puissant,
aux vertus magiques et curatives.
Et plus il est gros, plus il a de vertus et donc plus il est cher.
Les bézoards sont même parfois ornés sur de somptueuses montures en or.
Alors qu’on parle littéralement d’un corps étranger ou un amas de débris comme des poils ou des aliments, impossible à digérer.
C’est genre un caillou de vomi de chèvre, un peu quoi.
Et cette quête du merveilleux va mener à voir apparaître des prétendus restes d'animaux mythiques.
Les cornes de licornes par exemple, qui sont en fait des dents de narval, ont une place de choix chez les collectionneurs.
Malgré leur rareté, c'est LA pièce qui prouve à l’époque l’existence de cet animal légendaire.
Sa beauté fascine, par son ivoire torsadé mesurant parfois jusqu’à deux mètres de long.
La corne de licorne se vend entière, huit à dix fois le prix de son poids en or, ou en tranches fines, parfois en poudre.
Cet aspect de profit va faire la joie et la fortune des vendeurs et négociants de l'époque.
On voit alors se mettre en place un vrai marché de pièces fantastiques en tous genre qui se vendent à prix d’or
comme des museaux de poissons-scie qu’on fait passer pour des "langues de dragon",
ou des quartz qu'on identifie comme étant de "glace éternelle".
Naissent alors des véritables chimères taxidermisées, dans le but de prouver l’existence d’animaux légendaires
et de faire de la bonne grosse thune.
Moi ce que je préfère dans les cabinets de curiosité c’est les bestioles complètement foireuses.
Tu sais, les taxidermies complètement ratées, les trucs comme ça, c’est assez marrant.
D’ailleurs, y a des compils qui circulent sur le net,
et dans lot, il y en a un que j’aime beaucoup, c’est le lion de Gripsholm, je ne sais pas si tu connais.
Oui, il est comme ça :-b)
En fait, il date du XVIIIe, c’est quand le roi de Suède de l’époque a reçu un cadeau diplomatique.
Un lion vivant qu’il a mis dans ses jardins royaux en toute simplicité, en Scandinavie, normale.
Et quand ce lion est mort, ils ont pris sa peau, ses os tout ça, et ils ont tout donné à un taxidermiste en disant “accomplis ta magie”.
Sauf que le problème, c’est que le taxidermiste n’avait jamais vu de lion vivant.
Il n’avait pas la notice. Du coup, il a fait comme il a pu et force est de constater que ça ne ressemble à rien.
Mais c’est assez courant avec les animaux exotiques.
Les girafes aussi, les gens pensaient que les girafes n’existaient pas,
alors que de l’autre côté, ils avaient des cornes de licorne, tu l’as dit, dans leurs cabinets de curiosités, ça ne leur faisait pas peur. C'est assez marrant.
Dans le même genre, il y a l’ornithorynque, les premiers naturalistes qui ont reçu les ornithorynques, des cadavres comme ça,
ils ont dit “attendez, c’est un canular ce truc. Qui a collé un bec de canard sur un corps de castor."
Ils ont cherché les points de couture et tout. Ils ne les ont pas trouvé forcément.
De l’autre côté, ce qui est marrant, c’est qu’il y a des canulars qui passaient complètement inaperçus, à l’époque, ça allait très bien. Genre, la truite poilue.
C’est un mythe nord-américain et islandais,
des gens qui pensaient qu’il y avait des truites qui vivaient dans des eaux très froides et qui avaient développé des fourrures autour d'elles.
Il y a des mecs un peu rigolo qui se sont dit “On va coller des fourrures de lapin sur des truites, et on va les vendre comme ça, à ces gens un peu crédules”.
Et ça a très bien marché.
Dans le même genre, il y a le Jackalope.
Pareil, légende nord-américaine, d’un mix entre un jackrabbit (un lièvre) et une antilope. Donc un lièvre avec des espèces de cornes là.
Ça c’est ultra courant aux États-Unis,
il y en a plein qui ont des trophées avec des têtes de Jackalope.
Évidemment, ça c’est une supercherie. Le jackalope, pas Ronald Reygan.
Mais ce qui est marrant, c’est que ça se base sur une vraie histoire. En fait, tu peux voir effectivement des lapins et des lièvres qui se baladent avec des espèces de cornes sur le visage et tout.
En fait, ces cornes, ce sont des tumeurs dues à un papillomavirus, donc c’est pas cool pour eux.
Mais c’est rigolo parce que du coup, c’est là que la réalité rejoint la légende, un peu comme dans les cabinets de curiosité.
- Si c'est pas beau tout ça.
- C'est magnifique !
Finalement, il est très clair que les cabinets de curiosités sont à l’époque réservés à une élite.
C’est une activité réservée exclusivement à des bourgeois éduqués et fortunés,
qui ont plutôt une volonté de posséder et d’organiser le monde par eux même
dans un espace restreint plutôt que de partager et donner accès aux savants par exemple des pièces rares
qui poseront les fondements de notre histoire naturelle et de la classification moderne.
Les cabinets de curiosités sont petit à petit considérés au XVIIIe siècle, comme l’expression de la vanité de l’être humain.
Georges-Louis Leclerc, comte de Buffon, éminent naturaliste, n'hésitera pas à écrire dans son ouvrage "Histoire naturelle"
que les curieux sont des personnes aisées qui s’ennuient et collectionnent tout et n’importe quoi en dépensant des sommes astronomiques.
Et sous leurs airs de cabinets magiques et précieux, se cache une autre facette.
Ils font leur apparition en plein essor du colonialisme, les colons étant bien souvent soucieux de prouver aux autochtones leur supériorité,
qu’elle soit intellectuelle, morale ou spirituelle, dans des démonstrations de science ou encore de religion.
Et collecter et voler des objets exotiques de ces populations devient également monnaie courante.
Pour illustrer cette facette obscure, parlons de Hans Sloane, un médecin et naturaliste anglais du XVIIIe qui deviendra ensuite le fondateur du British muséum,
et dont le travail et le mérite se basent sur l'esclavagisme.
Cet homme passe sa vie à assembler et collectionner des objets et des spécimens rares provenant du monde entier,
dans un souci de concilier vision scientifique et création divine du monde au travers de ses découvertes.
Et sa collection brille par sa rareté : il réunit plus de 45 000 livres, 3500 manuscrits,
des herbiers, des insectes, des taxidermies, des minéraux, et ça par millier.
Mais pour obtenir ces pièces, il n’hésite pas à se précipiter sur les collections prestigieuses de ses confrères décédés,
pour s’attribuer le mérite de ces curiosités.
Il est d’ailleurs très peu apprécié du milieu, Newton n’hésitant pas à le qualifier de scélérat, de gredin, ou de véritable escroc.
Mais ça ne s’arrête pas là.
Lorsqu’il part rejoindre sa nouvelle femme en Jamaïque, il devient propriétaire d’esclaves dans des plantations de canne a sucre.
Et il méprise littéralement leur savoir botanique.
Il demandera à ces esclaves africains de lui montrer des spécimens de plantes rares, de lui faire visiter l’île,
et obtiendra un précieux savoir qu’il s’appropriera sans vergogne dans un livre nommé “Histoire de la Jamaique”
qui est en fait est concrètement rendu possible par l'esclavage.
Il ira même jusqu’à récupérer des banjos appartenant à des esclaves pour les mettre dans sa collection.
Quand il rentre en Angleterre, il demande aux marchands d'esclaves de lui envoyer des spécimens,
il collectionne alors les vêtements portés par les esclaves, les nœuds coulants et les fouets utilisés pour punir et exécuter les fuyards.
Il obtient des spécimens de peaux humaines, des crânes, et fait partie de cette première génération de savants intéressée à essayer de déterminer
s'il y a une base physique pour les différences raciales…
Les cabinets de curiosités sont aussi parfois le moyen d’offrir une démonstration de pouvoir d’une nation, voire d’une race.
Au fil des années, et sa santé qui décline vers 1730, Hans Sloane va germer l’idée de faire don de ses collections à sa mort à la nation,
dans un lieu accessible à tous, afin de montrer l’étendue de la beauté de la création divine.
En 1753, le Parlement britannique adopte le British Museum Act,
et le musée, rempli d’objets appartenant à d’autres cultures, ouvre ses portes le 15 janvier 1759.
Petit à petit, les cabinets de curiosités vont alors donner naissance à des lieux de conservation institutionnels, et des musées.
Ce sont les réels ancêtres de nos muséums d’histoire naturelle.
En plus de ça, la diversité des collections disponibles offre aux yeux des scientifiques des spécimens rares et uniques,
une réelle aubaine pour la science.
Si les savants moquent les cabinets de curiosités, ils admettent aussi leur importance.
En 1817, Jean Baptiste Lamarck publie un article sur les coquillages?
Sous ses propos critiques, il admet que si les scientifiques ont pu voir beaucoup de coquillages rares, et bien c’est grâce aux collectionneurs.
Et c’est sur ces collections que va se consolider l’idée d’avoir une classification du vivant.
Au XIXe siècle, ces pièces constituent la base même des collections des musées d’histoire naturelle et d’art.
Aujourd’hui encore, en arpentant des lieux comme le British Museum ou la galerie d’anatomie comparée du muséum d’histoire naturelle de Paris,
on peut encore sentir cet univers mettant en scène ses objets naturels et curieux.
Si les cabinets de curiosités sont revenus à la mode ces dernières années aux yeux du grand public en séduisant par leur étrangeté et leur aspect décoratif,
il est important de comprendre l’histoire de ces objets fascinants.
Sous leurs airs de gros bordels d’objets insolites, et malgré un passé bordé de colonialisme,
ils sont les premiers échantillonnages de ce qui constitue le fondement même de notre Histoire Naturelle moderne,
en participant à l’époque à des changements importants dans la vision et la compréhension scientifique de notre monde.
Bon bah voilà, c’est la première fois que je vous montre mon travail comme ça, donc je suis un peu stressée… mais le but, c’était vraiment de vous rendre hommage à chacun dans la maison.
Ah, un hommage carrément.
Oui, mais un hommage alternatif tu vois, qui sort des sentiers battus.
C’est mortel, y a même un bout de saucisson et un bout de pain que j’ai mangé la veille,
je pourrais pas être mieux représenté.
Mais… attends… c’est mes poils là ?
Ah bah, certains ont donné de leur personne apparemment.
Bah qu’est-ce qu’il y a, ça ne vous plait pas, c’est ça ?
J’en ai vu des trucs dégueulasses , mais là ! Je m’incline !
Elle me fatigue !
-C'est pas grave.
- Désolé, désolé.
M*rde, nan mais là c'est bon, promis, c'est la dernière !
Ce regarde de l'enfer.
On a perdu Marie !